みんなちゃんと自粛しとるかこんにちははじめ社長ですどうですか学生の皆さん急行し
ているところ多いと思うんですけどて高9校で焼却嫁さん
今こそ勉強するときだと思うんですよ
皆さん耀勲めてください今自粛しておうちにいる人ってまぁ大抵は僕の勝手な偏見です
よ
もし俺が高校生
とかだったなんですよみんな自粛してたら俺の友達とか絶対な場面がでゲームしたり
アニメ見たり遊んだりして時間するするとめちゃくちゃ多いと思うんですけども
この中でその中でその中でこのばごみと皆さん御縁でございます学校に行ったら皆も
その勉強するんですよ授業とかある種くらいまでしか食べまして勉強してるですけど
もうここでさらにライバルに差をつけるために頭のゲームしたらに飯
なんかしたら沿って南下このなんかアングレビデオのかして半ば以来して時間を何とも
勉強に咲くことによって周りの人と差がつくわけですよ
それも学校はないのでかなりのさ今ここで勉強して事態の収束して学校が始まっていざ
提出を受けてみます
偏差値97あります学生の皆さんライバルと差をつけるなら今勉強してください
今日初めてそうですというべきはサーフィンの紹介していきましょう皆さんしてると
思うんですけどもドクターグリップというシャーペンがあるんですよ
よく見たことある人多いと思います昔からあるやつですね
何がすごいかっていうと思ったこれプレイ機能降ったら芯が出る機能と後重心の低さ
ですね中心結構の下の部分にあるんでめっちゃ好軽い感覚で辛さっても
文字が書けるんですよという人間工学的実験データ元に人が動かしやすくて書きやすい
文房が目指して作られてマートのドクターグリップってやつなんです1991年から
発売されております
パイロットさん2に出してしまいましたね
ドクターグリップの小さくが発売されております
こちらドクターグリップ afa ございます矢部もパイロットさんが満を持し新作の
ドクターグリップを出してきました
勉強全力サポートドクターグリップエースめっちゃ金のついてますね
疲れにくいこれが多分低重心なんでしょうねまたそして俺ない機能が付いている
そちら生地サイン新保0タイミングを焦らせるしてフレフレ機能
芯が折れないのは何かをレンズとかデルガードとかで結構出てるんですよね
それを取り入れたドクターグリップということなのでしょうかラス1さんっていうのが
すごく気になりますねちょっと開けていきましょう
0.5の写真がいるシャーペンのカラーのバリエーションこれぐらいだったと思います
6色展開で船長早速上げていきましょうかっこいい4
多いめっちゃカッコイイけどなんか落ち着いてるデザインだろうか
ラックもいいですねネイビー
はいこんな感じですねもうなんか結構いい感じ濃色左からグラデーションターコイズ
ブルーグラデーションソーピングエディションネットワークくるでしょうね具合
以上ですなんかにドクターグリップの時このペン先が金属大惨事では金属だったんです
けども
ベースカラーはちょっとつけるとどんな感じになってますねそれは9分がメタリックに
なっていますなんか怖いです
こここういう金属熱と助けるとネスを分離する奴ってぜ草木がぶれるイメージメッツで
そこでちょっと今んとこ北不安です
ポケットにしまうこのクリップがレッスンドクターグリップぞそのままプラスチック
みたいな出来てるんですけども今回なんと金属ということでと来たグリップ付ルーム
開くと彼はこういうタイプです後ドクターグリップは多色のやつとかはこれでしたね
高級感が増しておりますデザインめちゃくそ位
いいそう
グラデーションカラーになっておりますねってここが僕はなぜ1 sin ここが
ラスト1個のサイン
やすいですどうやって表記されるんでしょうかちょっとまだわかりません
かっこいいな個人的にはこのカラーがメッツかっこいいしてなんかこれで勉強したら
モテそう
こうやって
いないのいいないい家いいなーかっこいいなー
見た目とても好きですだ第二7本と書きやすさとか
の芯が折れにくさとか二連星がどれくらいで安いのかそしてことが水小さいんとは何な
のか
ラスイチさん入っててもいいですねなんか固定すどこで書いて絶命した中では仕入れ
なきゃとって来て保存して時の時間直すこともで書いたものでそれから野良積載の機能
によってなければ者にはとても有効な機能だと思いました早速見ていきましょうね
2階
テレビすごいいい感じに芯が出ると思いますでは早速書いていきましょう
じっ
[音楽]
改定しているそんなクルドがみたいな機能ついてますねこれ
ペン先が潜って芯が折れないああああモーグルタイプねなるほどなる方ならとびっくり
した
クルート版の機能が付いてるかと思ったらなるほどなるほどちょっともうちょい帰って
みます
いやーさっすがドクターグリップで素晴らしい書きやすさ
やっぱ[ __ ]シーメイクイーンでここだけでこう小回りでかけるラックさあの家からい
なくてこうやってくれぐるぐるって言ってるだけでもう中学ってますめちゃくちゃ書き
やすい谷中ドクターグリップ好きな人とれ殴り書きが好きな人だと思ってるんですよね
あっえっ
あっ惚れ子だとレンジだとレンジだったらすごいすごいすごいすごいすごいなんかが
オレンジになってますそれでわかりやすく入ってたし
部長って早くらセットにしましたなんか加速ちゃんとオレンジのやってるんだ
まず書き心地めちゃくちゃいいです人間工学に基づいて書きやすい重心をしっかり
押さえて弱い力でもすらされた文字書くようになっていますからその塾先みてください
じゃあ普通のドクターグリップかけますね
10分
ん
塾先が動かないですよねノートに察知した時なんかドクターグリップ s だとタッチ
したとき
三水ください
10分
分かりませんです行きますよ
とって
ぼっくりっ
ねちょっと姉に会ってなるのは彼にすぐにあって中の金属のみたらこれがちょっと
クニャってなるんですよねこれが気になるかなってくらいです
アクティブサスペンションつってもペン先がモーグルんですよわざと
まずと書くとにシャー芯が折れないように木準備できててかなりの力で書いても折れ
ないっていうか俺内部そういう利点がありますねああ
これは人を選びますねめちゃくちゃ使いやすくて最高って人と何か私には似合いません
っていうに縦に分かれるタイプのサーフィンかなと思いました
やっぱ工具ねって子持っちゃうんで丁寧に書く女子とはいるじゃないですね大しても
言いますけど
高1自治きれいに帰ってちっちゃい子出会いしっかり書きたい人がなく
ちょっとちょっとその後ボール感じが逃げ戦になっちゃうかもしれませんただそれだけ
でもスピードあんな字汚くてもいいから早くノートを取りたいとかもうさせずだって
一家に落下してどうと取るかっていうそういう公立中になる人にやすごいお勧めかも
しれないです
なぜちゃいまほっとストレスフリーでメチャクチャ速く書けると思います後疲れません
させがドクターグリップです
アーニーね俺らめちゃくちゃ好きですねたぶん高校生が受験して
だったら普通にこれ使ってますなんかめっちゃオート良いカラーバリエーション展開と
かしてくれたらいいねなんかめざ草きれいな黄色とかもうめっちゃビビットなグリーン
とか超赤とか
メッツキーのとか
お願いしますじゃあ個人的にはすごい使いやすかったしやっぱ文房具ひとつ変えるだけ
で勉強のモチベーションでかなり上がると思うのでこの際ぜひドクターグリップ
エンスーゲットしてみてはいかがでしょうか
俺は好きでした俺はザ
[音楽]
ブーバーし